whoa guys if you watched my video on my
most anticipated films that come out in
2013 at the end of the video I mentioned
only God forgives the new collaboration
between Ryan Gosling and Nicolas Winding
Griffin the director of one of my
favorite films of all time drive and
today they released the trailer for only
God forgives I did not know was coming
out today
I don't know if they made an official
announcement about it in the past but I
watched it and I'm just I'm fanboying
out at this time when I was pregnant
with you
strange you're different I'm a
determinate you can call me a Ryan
Gosling or Nicolas Winding Reverend
fanboy I admit it I got a boner for both
of them that's perfectly fine
I completely admit that this trailer
looks fantastic if you are like me and
you're weary of finding out plot details
before film is released I assure you
this trailer doesn't give away anything
there's just fantastic cinematography a
very haunting musical score and some
impressive performances and sequences
hinted at in this trailer this movie
looks similar to drive in a few ways the
cinematography is brilliant however it
looks like it's a little more crime
oriented even than Drive was it takes
place in Bangkok and the cinematography
captured in this trailer my jaw dropped
and that is just mind-blowing to me as
someone who appreciates cinematography
or would like to be a director someday
there's only a few brief little hints of
the story within this trailer you have
Kristin Scott Thomas in there who
mentions perhaps that she's Ryan
Gosling's mother it's not a hundred
percent sure if that's who she's
referring to but she mentions that when
she was pregnant with this individual
she felt as if the baby wanted to be
aborted within her which I find very
disturbing and dark and then you see
Ryan Gosling dragging a man by his jaw
through a hallway this movie looks dark
intense and exciting and I'm really
looking forward to seeing this film
there have been hints that it might
premiere at the Conn Film Festival there
have been hints that it might premiere
the TIF Film Festival I will definitely
be going to Toronto later this year
I hope it's there I really hope I get to
see it there and if not it would be nice
if it was released even sooner but I
don't think it will be because there
isn't an official release date for
America yet there's a release date for
Denmark in May but not for America so
I'm assuming it'll probably be at the
Conn Film Festival and possibly at if
later it looks incredible I'm interested
in seeing what you guys think of the
trailer
I left a link below in the description
so you can go check it out yourself let
me know what you think and as always
guys thanks for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck my next
wanna fight